et tu sais quoi t'as pas je me disais
que je pourrais peut-être sortir un
disque d'humour zemmour tu as été
chanteur tight et danseurs d'être c'est
vraiment dur de percer
je ferais n'importe quoi pour y arriver
j'ai mis au point un nouveau personnage
on m'appelle de l'émail tu es pour
baiser ces [ __ ] je fais pas dans le
lait
[Applaudissements]
t'as fait quoi tes cheveux tu as l'air
d'un maquereau comme ça tout est
mascarade je viens de créer un
personnage sacré numéro tire ma tignasse
au je rêve ou est une perruque c'est ça
je fais tout ce que vous me demanderez
peu importe ce qu'il faudra faire pour
que cet album explose les charmes c'est
dégoûtant mais sache que tu as un
produit que tu peux ni vendre ni
promouvoir toute ma vie les gens m'ont
dit non je me dis parfois nous reste
devienne pas réalité monsieur ci ont
claqué la porte au nez
je trouvais une autre porte je veux que
le monde sache que j'existe ça ne fait
même pas rire et en plus ça y'a même pas
frangins dans si je peux être sous les
feux des projecteurs avec mon propre
fils
je pourrais être partout en même temps
on doit mettre de l'émail sur grand
écran
quand je me regarde je vous trouve un
peu plus en cher que les autres plus en
cher
regarde assez dur vu martin ce que je te
propose à toi c'est d'avoir un rôle dans
mon nouveau film tu t'es dit que tu
allais de pointer devant moi et aller
faire affaire non est si je te laisses
et des rires quand on raconte une
histoire il est toujours préférable
d'écrire sur ce qu'on connaît absolument
rien à raconter sur ma fille tu ma vie
c'est la nuit c'est les clubs les
propriétaires l'expert les proxénètes et
du couple
tu fais du karaté non mais j'apprends
vite je peux apprendre comment découper
un [ __ ] car action
c'est tout opale toi dessus ses droits à
tout le monde qu'il est une bête de sexe
je me demande sur quelle planète et
petits pains
si ce film est un flop tu vas bosser
gratuitement pour tout le reste de ta
vie je suis extrêmement reconnaissant de
m'avoir fait participer à ce fait j'ai
jamais vu une personne qui me
ressemblent dans les films qui passent
sur grand terrain
[Musique]
non monsieur tony martin s'était aussi
bon que dans chasse
[Musique]